[Music]
this I think is session 16 in this
series philosophers in the midst of
history and today we're looking at a
really big heavy hitter from the
medieval period Thomas Aquinas who still
has a significant influence today so I
thought I would talk a bit about his
historical situation the title has the
mendicant or orders so we're also
talking about these new developments in
religious life and then some of the
political system and the university
system that that's changing but I
thought we could like go down to the
present because people talk about Thomas
even today he's not
he never was the official Catholic
philosopher as I think a lot of people
who were Thomas it's like to portray him
but he he certainly is like first among
equals when it comes to Catholic thought
and he's even exercising a influence on
Protestant thought these days strangely
enough given that you know he used to be
the the one that they'd Catholics would
beat the Protestants over the head with
but they've kind of embraced him in the
present so we're talking about somebody
from the 13th century and you notice
like his the timeline he's born in 1225
he dies in his in his 50s 1278 doesn't
really live that long
I suppose we could say for a person of
his time you know that's fairly fairly
old he gets a lot done in that time and
I started the timeline with 1210 in part
because what you've got there is some
back history with one of the mendicant
orders and so in 1210 before Thomas is
born only 15 years before he's born you
have the Friars Minor the Franciscans
being approved by Pope Innocent the
third which means that they become an
official
order until then you had Francis and he
was you know he was doing his thing he
he decided to renounce his possessions
live this life of poverty you see you
well and you know seen the statues of
him with the animals you know preaching
to them and there's a you know there's
books that record what it was like for
the early Franciscans but getting that
approval was really central because that
means they are official now they are an
order within the church so that means
that they can do things they can you
know start spreading their their houses
at the same time there's also another
thing going on that we'll come back to
there's a provincial Synod and sends
that condemns teaching of aristotelian
texts we'll talk about why that that
matters in just a bit but it
particularly bears upon the city of
Paris where the university is developing
so you get the Friars Minor and notice
these are friars NOT monks not you know
father's not brothers
they're called friars in part because
they have a new function and they they
move from place to place
then the Poor Clares get founded so
you've got a female order connected with
the Franciscans in 1216 just six years
later the Dominican Order the order of
preachers is founded or approved rather
and then shortly after that 12 2012 21
you get Francis resigning leadership and
it's devolve another people Dominic dies
and so now you're getting into like the
second generation of leadership and
notice that Thomas is born just a few
years after that so to put it in like a
contemporary context now we are talking
about institutions within a much larger
Church to which there's really very
little you know opposition it's not like
here in America where we have like a
million different denominations and if
you don't like this one you can go join
it's more like there's one big unhappy
family and they have their different
sticks that they do and every once in a
while one group will break off and call
everybody else heretics and get called
heretics and and get persecuted and
usually get wiped out as a result but
you have these different different
groups with within the church and the
mendicant orders are called mendicants
in part because they they move from
place to place the other earlier orders
like the Benedict ins for example they
took a vow of stability so you would
become a monk or you become a nun and
then you go to this monastery or this
convent and you're gonna stay there the
rest of your life most likely unless
unless you get assigned to go somewhere
else
like you know really successful you know
monastery might have branches in
different places as people bequeathed
property that to them so for example say
the Ansem he winds up in England
overseeing some property that the
monastery of Beck which is in Normandy
owns but but for the most part you're
gonna stay in the same place I mean you
might go on a pilgrimage
you know you might go somewhere else to
get some books there's a copy but you're
gonna always come back to the same
location and you're gonna live there in
common with the mendicant orders there
they're not free agents right there
they're under the authority of whoever's
in charge but they can get sent anywhere
so it's a in a way it's a more flexible
organizational structure right the
Franciscans the the Dominicans the
Augustinians and the Carmelites those
are the four big ones at that time they
can send people everywhere if you want a
new you know house of studies out in the
sticks and Italy just you know pick six
guys and send them down there you know
and they ended up this is a little bit
outside of the scope of our discussion
here but that's part of why you notice
the Dominicans and the Franciscans
Carmelites and later on the Jesuits who
somewhat haven't meant to kick order
before they became a more established as
a society they in don't did all this
mission work they did all this
exploration because it was possible just
to like shoot them out there whereas
like if you want to start a new Benedict
in thing you gotta have a whole
monastery right so Thomas is is you know
going to be attracted to this and his
parents are not really in favor of it
you know he comes from this this you
could call them lesser nobility there
were all these hierarchies of nobility
that were kind of shifting from time to
time and his family you know he was part
of this this lower nobility which is
upper-class but not like the upper upper
class not the policymakers right more of
the policy executors sort of like upper
middle management you can say in a
corporate structure not middle
management where you're right in the
middle and you get crap from below and
crap form on top nicer to be you know
you're not enough to CEO but maybe
you're a vice president or something
like that so you know Thomas's family
they're naturally a bit more
conservative when it comes to this and
he actually as a kid just five years old
is sent to this Benedict in Abbey to
begin his his studies at Mount Casino
which I think you know most of us know
mainly from like world war two times but
it was it was an important place back
back then and you know the Benedict ins
were really well established they were
like the status quo when it came to
religious life so you know it'd be sort
of like would it be the equivalent you
know like going or often getting your
your professional degree and getting a
good job just you're you know you're
gonna be a monk you're not gonna have
sex and you're not going to produce any
children but you know you're gonna be
part of the religious structure and part
of the political structure at the time
with the Franciscans and the Dominicans
and
the Carmelites and these these new
orders they're sort of like a bunch of
bums from the perspective of you know
other people you know they're wandering
around begging for money they don't have
you know well-established properties
they've only been around for you know a
couple generations who knows who these
people are and they're saying wild stuff
you know the Benedictines by this time
they're you know they're still you know
religious but they're kind of
predictable and sedate you don't see a
lot of really important benedict and
thinkers around this time although there
were some really important ones in the
earlier parts of the Middle Ages like
Anselm or Alcoa nor bead you know these
these important doctors and thinkers
these are the the mendicant orders is
where all the exciting stuff is
happening so I'm not going to say that
it's quite like a cult
but think of it as sort of like you know
when these new religious denominations
come into existence here in America
because we're the birthplace for quite a
few of them there's a lot of people are
like man those people are wild you know
they seem Christian but they've got some
new interpretation and I don't know if I
can wrap my head around this then I'm
not sure if I like them around here in
our town they're they're doing things
very differently that's the way these
these orders were and and it took a
while before they they became you know
part of the status quo again so Thomas
studies at this Benedictine abbey and
then eventually in 1238 he comes back to
Naples and he studies at a Benedictine
house where he's doing what they call
the studium Generale a this course of
studies and its affiliated with the the
university there and in the studium
Generale he encounters Aristotle for the
first time something again well we'll
come back to and talk quite a bit about
but what ends up happening is he he's
attracted to the Dominicans he sees that
the activity that they're involved in he
thinks that they're really interesting
guys that that's where the real action
is for him and the Dominicans let me
back up a little bit
Dominic founded his order the order of
preachers to combat to do a couple
things one was to to sort of improve the
level of education among Catholics among
you know especially priests and and and
people doing parish work and and you
could think of them as sort of like the
the the team that you would send into a
place when things are really screwed up
but he was really motivated by this this
outbreak of a what came to be enabled as
a heresy of alba gen Zionism in the
South of France and the people who were
involved with that were pretty bright
and so he realized that you're not going
to just you know bring people away from
this by stamping it out with force or
you know inducements you're gonna have
to argue your way against them and for
people to come back into you know the
Orthodox Church
so the Dominicans are devoted to
learning and properly learning for its
own sake and in part because the mind is
is something given to you by God and why
wouldn't you want to improve it this is
an old theme going all the way back into
the early days of Christian philosophy
people like Augustine and be theists in
the beginning of the Middle Ages and
further back to Justin Martyr and
clement of alexandria you know there's
this healthy respect for the human
intellect as a divine gift but you also
want to develop it so that you're not
going to get taken in by heresy and so
you can help other people who are being
taken in by it as well to find their way
out of it and so the order of preachers
is founded in part to to combat those
those tendencies so thomas is attracted
to this and he joins the Dominican Order
without permission from his family back
then and you might say well why the hell
would you have to ask them right
it wasn't he a grown adult by then well
yeah but you know
things were much more traditional and
you know especially if you belong to a
family where every single action that
you do has some sort of political
implications you would want to at least
check in and he doesn't check in and
instead he follows his you could say his
heart but really his head and in 1244 he
receives the dominican habit now the
Dominicans were white and wearing the
habit would be a clear sign that now
he's with them so when he joins them now
sort of all bets are off the family
knows that he's joined them he they were
like you know if you're going to join
somebody join the Benedict ins you know
they're perfectly good order you know
they're well established our families
connected with them look you've studied
with those guys why wouldn't you take
and be sort of like you know you've been
offered the chance to go to University
of Chicago all right you've got all the
the paperwork right there and you're
like you know I think I want to go to
dental school instead or I think that's
gonna be I'm gonna cut air you know or
I'm gonna go join a rock band you know
your family would probably be kind of
ticked off and what they do is they
imprison him and they hold him for about
a year now it's it's house arrest it's
not like he's in shackles or anything
like that but he's not allowed to leave
these castles that his family owns and
he tutors his sisters while he's doing
that he comes with a pretty big family
he's got a lot of siblings and two of
his brothers is a really famous story
about the the guy two of his brothers
hire a prostitute to come in because
they figure if they can get into sleep
with the prostitute he's gonna get all
of this you know I want to be a friar
business out of his head he probably
won't be a Benedictine monk but at least
he won't be a Dominican friar and then
they can go on with with life right and
so he drives the prostitute out of the
rooms and get away from me Satan and
then the family is like well I don't
know what we're gonna do with this guy
and eventually his mother arranges for
him to escape and he does and he is
they come to terms of the fact that he's
going to be a Dominican and he travels
to Paris where he studies with this guy
Albert Magnus and Albert Magnus
he was a generation older than Thomas
but not that much more and he's called
Albert Magnus Albert the Great he was
one of the greatest minds of his own
time and you might say well why Paris
well you know by that time Paris was a
political center for French kings who
are not particularly strong compared to
the you know the English kings or the
Holy Roman Emperor but you know sort of
a distant third right so that's
important and there was a cathedral in
Paris right notre dumb and there were
all these other established things
within paris all these schools and you
know monasteries and other churches and
and very often connected with them there
would be some sort of school activities
so Paris is already an intellectual
center and by the time that Thomas is
going there there is a university and
this is beyond any sort of studium
Generale a right this is beyond any sort
of like starting school now it's like a
full-fledged course of study and there
were basically three main things that
you could study at university in in the
Middle Ages as your terminal degree you
could go for other stuff right so the
terminal degrees were theology Paris was
the place for that or medicine and then
law and why those three why not you know
business well there weren't any business
degrees back then right as a matter of
fact the bourgeoisie is just starting to
rise and become important around that
time why not philosophy well philosophy
was studied but it was studied so that
you could do so you ultimately could do
theology better or do law or medicine
better philosophy was sort of the it
wasn't quite a beginning core
it was actually fairly far into it but
philosophy was supposed to serve one of
these these three purposes and so
anybody who actually had a law degree
would have studied some philosophy
anybody who had a medical degree or two
studied some philosophy and you would
have to study the the seven liberal arts
as well so have your your the terms like
Trivium and quadrivium before no so this
is a sort of a classical education
structure and people talk about it today
but usually it's mostly just at these
very conservative schools where they're
like we're going to go back to you know
classical education and sometimes they
do it well and sometimes they don't
because you know we need more than just
that but at that time they talked about
seven liberal arts and so you had four
that were oriented towards mathematics
in some way and for that we're oriented
or three that were oriented towards
language so the the quadrivium you have
you know arithmetic and geometry we
place them both under math now because
we've figured out how to combine them
but at that time they were seen as two
different arts astronomy and then what
would you guess the other one would be
that's somehow connected to mathematics
it's not Lancer because that would be
under geometry music use ratios right so
like the you know when you when you play
a string and you put your finger right
in the middle of it you get the octave
and then there's other things that you
can do and when you arrange the notes in
certain ways you get different responses
and they knew this going all the way
back to you know ancient ancient Greece
as a matter of fact there was a student
of Aristotle we don't have much of the
guy and I don't remember his name he
studied with Aristotle and something
must have happened because he had a lot
of bad stuff to say about her stuff it's
a matter of fact a lot of the colonies
that we have about Aristotle being a bad
guy come from this this this particular
guy exterior eristic Seamus I think is
his name here at a he wrote a book on
harmony
a lot of other books but we only have a
few of his things but they were studying
it right so you've got the you got these
for art's over here and for each of
those arts you would have professors who
specialized in that so if you were a
student you would go into this guy's
class and study you know somebody
writing about music it might be boy
theists as on harmony or something like
that you'd have textbooks that were you
know essentially what somebody else had
written about that and your class might
just be like learning it by rote or it
might be very engaging depending on who
the teacher was so that was that that
section over there and then you had the
three arts that were oriented towards
language grammar and grammar included
what we would nowadays called literature
so it's very much like our English
curriculum where we have language arts
and then we have literature right so why
would you you know combine the two well
you look at good literature to figure
out what good writing looks like so you
would read some poetry and you'd read
some history and you'd read some other
stuff in there and then rhetoric was
another one of the arts and that's to
help you speak persuasively to write
well to communicate your thoughts in in
ways that can convince an audience
because you pay attention to your
audience and then the other one was
called dialectic we often gloss it as
logic but it included a bit more than
logic because it also included what we
would call the processes of inquiry
right or where to where to get your
ideas from and how to tell which ones
not to put too fine a point on which
ones are crazy and BS and which ones
they actually has some good some value
and in those those as well they read the
literature that's available to them so
when new books would become available
they would study those and so you would
take all this this curriculum and then
he would take your philosophy stuff and
then you'd go on to whatever else it is
that you're going to to study and it was
you know kind of a structure
or really way of doing things the
students apparently like to party quite
a bit you know just like students do
today just like students did in our time
they would often get in all sorts of
crazy you know problems with each other
and many of the many of them were
actually in religious orders while they
were - that's so they would make their
religious orders look a bit bad but you
know they were they're adolescents
essentially and young young men doing
their thing and this is what Thomas goes
to so he's entering in there with Albert
Magnus Thomas was looked at as being
from his fellow students as being not a
very bright guy because he didn't talk
much and he was also apparently quite
big you know he might have had a
glandular problem or something like that
so they called him the dumb Hawks and
Albert said of him someday that dumb ox
is going to you know I forget exactly
the wording something like Heba have a
roar that will shake all crisps and um
and it turns out to be quite true done
you know the other students of Albert
Magnus they were they weren't bad guys
they weren't Thomas Aquinas quality guys
and Albert is introducing Thomas not
just to philosophy and and you know also
theology in general he's he's you think
of the way that you worked with somebody
else back then is being sort of like
learning a craft you know you you
apprentice with somebody you work
closely with them you ask them what
you're doing after you actually do it
and then they give you the explanation
and you develop a sense for it the way
that they did philosophy and theology
back then was partly by commenting on
works that they had so you would read a
work and then you would say here's what
the author is saying here and this is
what it's connected to in other cases
you might do this for a work of
philosophy you might do this for a work
of theology you might do this for a
biblical text
you know like Book of Isaiah or the book
of Saul
and that was one big part of what they
would do commentary tradition and he
would take into account other people's
commentaries so there's this long
pattern and then you would also have
this this process of arguing for and
against and and this goes back you know
at least a good ways it's not it's not
something radically new in Thomas's time
but more and more people are doing it
it's what we call the Scholastic method
where you take like you take a topic
right just God exists so if you have you
know question like then none of the
people then back then probably actively
entertain the idea that maybe God didn't
exist but they wanted to explore the
question so how do you do that well you
you know take both sides say one side
saying yes God exists
the other side saying no God doesn't
exist and then what do you have to do
you have to look for why somebody would
believe this this side and why somebody
would believe this side so how do we
typically do that if I tell you that you
should what what sort of car do you
drive
okay so if I want to convince you that
you should get rid of your Honda and buy
a Subaru instead I Drive Subaru and you
know my wife really loves Subaru you
know it's such a such a great car blah
blah blah right what do I have to do in
order to convince you well you you you
have to give me the arguments for you
know for why yours you know why your car
is better I mean exactly yours what's
not so good at mine yeah so if I'm
arguing the fore side I've got to have
at least one argument you know it's got
better gas mileage is probably not true
you know but I can say that anyway right
and then you might be arguing the other
side and say no I think mine's got
better gas mileage and here's why all
right
and we've referenced some something
there's probably some website out there
you know it's a better investment it
holds its Blue Book value better right
you actually get out the Bluebook and
we're looking at or something like that
so you site authorities and you make
arguments and you try to pile up the
stuff on on one side because it's always
better to have more than one argument
and then you might pile up the stuff on
the other side and then you look at the
arguments and you're lying well this
one's pretty good
this one is garbage you know only an
idiot would buy this line of reasoning
this one okay it's kind of correct but
we got to tweak it a bit and and and
qualify it a bit it's corrected in this
way but it's not correct in in general
and you do that for both sides that's
how they did philosophy and that's how
they did theology and the idea was by
doing that you are sort of canvassing
the field to see what other people have
had to say about it so you're not
reinventing wheels you're using the
available body of information that you
have right you also get to show off how
much you know which I think was
something that appealed to a lot of them
but but not only are you canvassing all
this you're going through it critically
and deciding what parts you want to keep
and what parts you want to get rid of
and then you arrive at a conclusion yes
God exists or God doesn't exist and
we've got good reason to think that
because of this and this and this and
that's what Thomas is learning from
Albert but also from other other people
who are doing that at the time and it's
going to go into his own method where
you see him doing this with with the
genres that he's writing in particularly
the disputed question genre disputed
questions are where you've got a
question and you know you take that
here's the ten arguments on this side
here's the five arguments on this side
as a matter of fact one of these five
arguments is actually the best one but
we need to say a few more things about
it that's what what Thomas does in a lot
of his works and he does something very
similar in his most important work which
is the so metallo guy which he
unfortunately didn't finish will get
we'll get to that in just a moment he
does the same sort of thing where he'll
say is the will free right so you'll
have a question you know about the will
and then he'll have an article is the
will free and then he'll have you know
three arguments or four arguments you
know know the will is not free because
Augustine said this and we tweaked it
this way and we get this right and then
he'll come to another point where he
says well on the contrary so-and-so says
this and then only after doing that will
he give you his view he'll say I respond
that and then he takes into account when
everybody else has had to say on it adds
a bit more and comes to some sort of
conclusion so many addresses the the the
different arguments that have been given
in what he calls responses to objections
this is a really great I mean it's not
the only way to do philosophy by any
means but it's a really great way to do
it that's a great way to do sociology
it's a great way to do art you know
theorizing about art it's a great way to
think about HR problems you know it's
not again not the only possible way but
it's it's kind of good to adopt that
dialectical method and so Thomas does
that going back to the the timeline
so he's studying with Albert Magnus in
Paris and he writes one of his one of
his first works there des fallacious
host on no beliefs artistas and then he
goes to Cologne another important
university town with Albert Magnus now
notice
why is he hopping around like this well
they're Dominicans and they get sent to
where the order thinks the intellectual
needs are right they're sort of like
guys on you know a military mission
almost right you go where the commander
tells you to go
he gets ordained in Cologne
unfortunately his his home you know turf
of Aquino gets destroyed in this this
fight with between innocent the the
fourth the Pope who's at war with these
successors of frederick ii conrad the
for that man
the Holy Roman Empire and the papacy are
at war with each other quite a bit of
the time and Thomas's family is right in
the middle of this right one of his
brothers is actually starved in prison
his brothers were you know most of them
are Knights so they're they're taking
part in the military stuff
he returns to Paris and he starts
writing some more stuff then eventually
he becomes elevated to master of
theology now this is this is what we
would call a terminal degree you know we
we look at things today we're like uh
your masters you don't have a doctor you
know you don't have a PhD you're nothing
all right well masters was the top of
the food chain at that time and so being
being elevated to master meant that that
he was you know essentially equipped to
be teaching and to also take part in
other things the governance of the
university which which is quite
important and he starts writing other
important words now the spellcheck
unfortunately changed some of these
things so to change day enta and a sense
iakh into day m to ed essential but it
should be on being in essence right and
he starts writing also scriptum super
libros and theorem that is an important
shun rrah where you're writing on these
these questions that other people have
you know asked and answered about
important topics it's sort of like it's
a way of doing practical work within
your discipline you can say now after
that in 1259 he gets sent out to do I
get more more intellectual mission work
he gets sent to Italy to teach at four
different places eventually anon G or
viento Rome and Viterbo which I think
are of a terrible University out in La
Crosse is probably named after and there
he during this time he starts writing
the the quest Tiana's to
bouton today very Itachi this is again
that that disputed questions thing this
is about truth and in that well I'll
sort of like digress about that for a
minute so one of the things that you see
Thomas doing is trying to read
everything he can everything that's
available any anything that he can get
his hands on he is going to read he
doesn't actually do his own writing he
has a scribe to do that he could dictate
it's a fact but which is kind of a
luxury right because you know the
picture writing with all that stuff but
books are you know kind of hard to get
ahold of in the Middle Ages and he's he
happens to be living at a time when
communications are expanding the
educational institutions are popping up
all over the place
more and more books are being produced
new books are becoming available new to
them not not radically new although
there were a lot of other new things
that they were reading produced by their
own contemporaries or near
contemporaries so he has the opportunity
to read much more widely than somebody
say a Benedictine monk in you know a
century and a half before him well a
century before him well no it would be a
century and a half like an some would
have had and some had much fewer
resources than Thomas Aquinas had even
somebody in a University of town of
Paris like Abelard Peter Abelard
about a generation and a half after
Ansem doesn't have access to as much
stuff as Thomas does so Thomas is able
to incorporate all this stuff and in the
disputed questions on truth
interestingly an some is one of the
people whose works he cites quite a
quite a lot because Anselm rota a work
on truth so all this stuff is
circulating around and Thomas is trying
to combine it all into a new synthesis
which is quite difficult to do for
reasons we'll talk about in a bit 1260
he begins writing one of his major works
the Summa contra Gentiles the when we
have this word some means the the we
literally some but like the totality or
the whole like the book that you would
need right we have books like that where
we say this is the one book the only
book that you're gonna need on this it's
like a handbook or I forget exactly what
word we use there's a word out there in
in literary genres right but see the
summit contra Gentiles is against the
Gentiles you might say well isn't Thomas
a Gentile he's not a Jew he means it to
be directed against anybody who's not a
believer in the Christian faith so it's
a way to try to provide arguments for
anyone who might encounter say a Jew or
a Muslim or a pagan or an Albanian or
whoever
right it's it's a work of apologetics in
the in essence now a little bit after
that urban lose the Pope sends for Tom
Thomas to write for this reunion with
the Greeks that one of the things are
constantly trying to do and some
actually got roped into this as well the
eastern and western churches you know
they'd split apart not only along
practical lines and and linguistic lines
and some history but but also
doctrinally and so they were trying
pretty you know consistently to bring
the two the two churches back together
into one and they never really pulled it
off usually Anthony was both sides would
make arguments against each other over
things like you know should the bread
for communion be lavender unleavened
right and some for example has a piece a
very short letter on why the bread
should be on be unleavened you know and
the earth attacks arguing the other they
were never able to get past these these
sorts of things and some of it had to do
with politics as well you know there's
the Byzantine
in the east you've got the Roman Empire
what's left of it you know the Holy
Roman Empire the Pope all these other
constituencies in the West anyway going
going back down so 1265 Thomas begins
working on the summit alo VI which is
his much more important work he never
did finish the summit a low-key but he
got a lot done on it and again a little
bit of a side note so the soma is when
people say Thomas Aquinas teaches XYZ
they're usually taking it from the
summit a lob a that's the work that he
developed interestingly enough look the
preface to it it says it's actually for
beginners and what kind of beginners you
know you read this stuff you know who
does he have in mind here right this is
really complicated stuff he starts out
with like you know the nature of
theology and then does God exist and
divine simplicity and divine goodness
and there's all this complicated stuff
in there but interestingly it really is
written for beginners the Latin language
in it is deliberately I won't say simple
but made as as readable as possible
there's no flourishes of rhetoric or
side jokes or anything like that it's
written to be accessible it's written
for the the regular Joe who happens to
you know be studying theology and it's
probably gonna be a parish priest out
there and stick somewhere so he's got to
know when he does confessions and runs
into new unforeseen problems how the
hell he's gonna handle this stuff he
needs to be armed with some some
intellectual knowledge so that he can
make sense out of problems without you
know like asking the bishop who probably
doesn't know either so the summit a low
GI is is written in part to provide this
sort of systemic overview of Christian
doctrine in an argumentative way in a
way that's supposed to promote thinking
not not just be like memorized or
anything like that it's supposed to be a
text that produces practitioners of
Christianity isn't that an interesting
idea for a text so he starts working on
this and he you know the first part is
all about God but one thing here's
another sort of digression to anything
that you want to find in Thomas it's
never just in the one place where you'd
expect it to be so like he's got you
know if you look at the the Summa
theologia it's got all these different
questions so you know question two is on
the existence of God you know and that's
that's you know nice and then like
question in this in the Prima Secunda
the first part of the second part
question
91 if I'm remembering right is about the
natural law right
but what Thomas says about the natural
law it's only partially contained there
he's also gonna mention it over here and
over here and over here and over here
and in order to figure out exactly what
he thinks about something you got to
grab these different pieces and bring
them together and then you like you get
kind of a composite picture and he
imagines you're gonna actually read the
whole book well the whole the whole
massive set of volumes that comprises
the thing a lot of people try to skim it
they're like I'm just gonna go to the
section about this because that's where
Thomas will tell me about that and then
they miss all the other things that he
has to say and they don't get the full
picture another thing I'll say too by
way of digression I you know I know a
lot of people who say that they read the
Summa theologia anybody who ever tells
me they've read the whole thing I never
believed them because I haven't read the
whole thing you know it's it's a massive
work and to do the job of actually going
through the whole thing just like when
people say I've read the whole Bible
really you read the parts where like in
chronicles there were like you know 78
men with spears from you know this place
and five chariots of brass from this
place and the list goes on for a couple
pages you read you read through all that
stuff and
I don't think so or these genealogies
these endless so-and-so baguettes this
guy this guy this guy you know or so you
know even somebody says they've read all
150 Psalms I don't believe it most of
the time that somebody tells me that so
anyway the so Matteo yeah he begins
working at it and he just continues
working at it and remember he's got a
guy who's there to take notes for him as
a matter of fact I think at one point he
had three different scribes so he's
still traveling around he's still
teaching and and part of what he's doing
in traveling to these different places
is establishing new houses of study new
studium Generale a places I'd be new
studia general general what general ah I
think so new places where people are
going to become initiated into learning
mostly young men you know he gets
brought back to Paris to argue against
the avarice including one of the main
teachers there siger of Brabant so this
is another thing that we need to like
sort of go off on a little digression
about who are they avarice and and you
know what would they be doing in Paris
and you know what difference does that
make and why is Aristotle involved well
in the Middle Ages in the West they lost
most of Aristotle's works they also lost
most of Plato's works as well the works
that they had were the ones that
Boethius had translated into Latin and
unfortunately if you remember the story
about boethius he had this great project
he was in translate all the Plato's
works and all of Aristotle's works from
Greek into Latin and if he lived he
would have done that and the Middle Ages
would have been a very different place
unfortunately he gets put under house
arrest and then executed and he's only
got a few done he did a
he did a translation of Aristotle's
categories and a commentary on that and
a translation of Aristotle's very short
work on interpretation so none of the
other stuff is available it's available
on the Eastern Roman Empire the
Byzantine Empire because they still have
Greek texts and they speak Greek but
it's not getting transferred back to the
the West in Spain however particularly
in Toledo you have all of these Jews and
Christians and Muslims living in this
quite you know polyglot pretty
enlightened Muslim but you know fairly
relaxed legal system kind of area and
what that ends up leading to the the the
Arabs had preserved Aristotle they
handed in the Aristotle's texts so these
these Roman element these Western Latin
scholars go down there and a big new
project of translation starts happening
translating Aristotle's texts into Latin
so that somebody like Thomas Aquinas who
really can't read Greek can relax
can read what Aristotle has to say they
know that Aristotle is very important
philosopher they just don't have that
much of them until these translations
start finding their way north north and
west from from Spain and by the time
that Thomas is writing they've got all
these texts available and they also have
the texts of these commentators so there
were there were some commentators on
Aristotle who were quite ancient like
Alexander of Aphrodisias for example
then there were some who were actually
Christian scholars like John de masking
who's not I mean he was doing his own
thing he writes this this exposition of
the Orthodox faith but there's all this
Aristotle in
you know so you've got these
commentators who are saying stuff about
what Aristotle has to say and there's an
entire chain of them in the Muslim world
leading up to one who many people
consider to be one of the best even
rushed latinized as Avalos before them
you have you know Al Farabi
and it been seen and even have people
who are like Al ghazali they know their
Aristotle they think Aristotle's wrong
and they think that you know a different
interpretation of you know religion and
philosophy ought to be a spouse so he
writes a book called the incoherence of
the Philosopher's Ovid arose defends
philosophy and by that he means
Aristotelian philosophy with a book
called the incoherence of the
incoherence all right so you've got this
long chain of tradition they're getting
translated into Latin so you know
intellectually curious people they like
to when when they get new stuff they
want to know what what's going on in
that and when they encounter thought
that's it's talking about the same stuff
that they're interested in like the
freedom of the will and you know how the
emotions work and whether there is a God
and how the heavens you know a cosmology
right how the heavens operator was there
a beginning in time or is the earth
eternal and what happens with our souls
when we die all that sort of stuff is
being talked about by these guys but
it's being talked about with different
frameworks different concepts and some
of the people in in Paris especially are
embracing this and running with it as
far as they can go and you know if you
take your Aristotle straight and you
read some of these commentators you
might get some ideas that don't jibe all
that well with traditional Christian
doctrine for example Aristotle said that
this the soul is the form of the body so
that means when the body dies that's it
there isn't any immortality if there is
an immortality it would be you know
maybe the highest part of ourself Plato
said something like this too in the
Timaeus
it would be you know maybe the agent
intellect which is a new idea coming
about right and maybe that agent
intellect in you and me is really the
same thing so there's no like personal
immortality just the the thinking part
of you survives and goes will have to
join the big whatever thinking soul and
my part does the same thing right well
you know if you if you start saying
stuff like that in a Christian framework
Christians might get ticked off right so
what's happening then it's kind of
similar to what's happening you know
although in a different way here in our
own academic system right here I'll go
off on a little bit of a rant so you see
all these conservatives who haven't
spent much time in universities saying
oh you know students are going into them
and they're being indoctrinated into and
that the names change all the time used
to be relativism now it's postmodern is
post modernist Marxism and identity
politics and the instructors are just
indoctrinating them and you know you
listen to this sort of stuff and you're
like man have you ever spent any time in
a college classroom I would love if I
could indoctrinated my students because
they don't listen to what I'm saying
half the time and they don't do the
reading that I expect them to a lot of
the time and what you know even the
smart ones who I can tell they're paying
attention and are asking good questions
in class I asked them about stuff that
we studied like four weeks later and
they don't remember any of it right so
how the hell is some indoctrination
gonna be taking place now that said I do
have a lot of colleagues who are clearly
far on the left and would love to be
indoctrinating their students and are
doing their best to do that it's just
not sticking and so you have the same
similar dynamic with with people being
very worried about this Aristotelian ism
and a borough is 'm avro ism is this you
know the interpretation of Aristotle
that's coming through Averroes
and it includes things like the notion
that hey maybe the universe didn't have
a start it could be a turtle for all we
know you know I mean I know that the
religious people think that God created
the heavens in her
happened in some determinate sequence at
some point in time not necessarily too
literal like days way even you know back
in the time of Augustine Augustine was
like listen that that's not to be
interpreted literally but there has to
be a beginning point God creates and
time begins then there's no time before
that the avro us were like well you know
just saying you take away that religious
doctrine and this rational account sure
seems to be pretty good you know maybe
there isn't the beginning in time maybe
the universe really is eternal now you
know that it's sort of like the status
quo of science we think there's a big
bang but if you went back a hundred
years
most scientists back then thought that
the universe was eternal the Big Bang is
actually relatively new on the scene so
that leads to some internal well it's
not even just internal it involves the
whole city and it also involves the
bishop so the bishop this guy 18:10
pierre he decides to condemn doctrines
and the first condemnation that he does
happens in 1270 now this is not the
first time that this sort of thing
happened they had another bishop for
Oxford condemning doctrines earlier
there are a couple other Parisian
bishops who are doing that so when you
got a university town
you got a key in it kind of keep track
of these these radical professors who
might be you know filling the students
mind with with this avarice garbage
right and so Tempe air brings in this
guy Henri of Ghent who is a Franciscan
the Franciscans were considered more
reliable with this that they they were
less prone to take on Aristotle and then
the way that the Dominicans and and some
of the other non non affiliated
professors were doing and so they
condemned these thirteen doctrines and
all it's really a few of them so the
first one is that the intellect of all
men is numerically
the same which would imply that that me
and you and anybody else we all have the
same basic intellect and we just can't
share it so think of it sort of like I
mean if we want to use today's
comparisons it would be sort of like our
intellects are all based in the cloud
right we're all there in cloud computing
none of it
or like Apple music right none of the
music is they actually on our phones
anymore it's all stored in some server
and you know if my phone gets destroyed
that's fine I just get a new phone and
connect up with the account and there we
go right the second one or the yeah here
we go the third one that the will of
managed wills or chooses out of
necessity okay that it's understandable
why they wouldn't want to accept that
doctrine if our wills are necessitated
then we can't say things that we do are
right or wrong or you know that we
should get punished or anything number
six was that there never was a first man
there never was an atom number yeah
number 10 that God does not know
individual things you might be able to
get this from an interpretation of
Aristotle so and that same with a number
11 that God does not know things other
than himself because you know Aristotle
talked about God as mind thinking itself
so you know you can get these
Aristotelian doctrines and 1810 PA is
condemning them he's saying anybody
who's teaching this stuff we're going to
forbid them from teaching they're gonna
be excommunicated and over the coming
years the the list rose to 15 and then
they start you know adding more and more
and more and more and by the time that
were in 1277 when the next really big
thing happens and the Pope gets involved
Pope John the 21st they have 219
propositions that are being condemned
right so now some of these you you can
look at them and there's there's people
who did work on this so I
wanted to to talk a little bit about
this here's one scholars take at it of
these 219 propositions only 79 can be
identified in the works of siger of
Brabant and boëthius of Dacia who seem
to be two of the main targets these are
guys who are teaching in the the
university or three anonymous writings
78 of 72 propositions nobody knows where
they're coming from the attribution is
uncertain 68 propositions couldn't be
identified at all nobody knows why they
got there themselves into this list but
it's really systematic it's like you
know here's all these propositions about
the will all these propositions about
creation all these propositions about
divine knowledge
if anybody's teaching this stuff they're
in trouble right
and some of Thomas's teachings if you
twist it in the right way could seem
like they're saying that sort of stuff
but you really have to do a lot of
twisting and there was some some worry
that that Thomas himself could could get
into trouble later on you know his uh
his work would be oops I don't have the
oh here we go
later on his work would be sort of
formally ratified as without error and
and as a matter of fact it goes on to
you know get more and more and more
celebrated at least within the Dominican
Order and eventually within the larger
Catholic Church now Thomas himself dies
before all of this happens and you
notice that by 1273 he stops working on
his his stuff and some of this comes
about because he has these mystical
experiences one of which leads him to
say that all that he has done up until
this point is like straw meaning it's
valueless at the time that he is working
and then
cuts off work he has started the third
part of the Summa theologia he might
have brought it to execution we don't
know we don't really know how much more
he was going to do he was also working
on a commentary on the Psalms and Thomas
thought that the Psalms were
particularly important there was a
tradition back then that every one of
the Psalms it speaks about you know the
conditions of the person who's narrating
it could be David it could be Solomon it
could be a couple other people and
Thomas you know had a different he had
his own mode of biblical interpretation
we've got a literal level and then
you've got what he calls the moral level
where it's you know the literal levels
about with what the thing is and then
what it's saying and then the moral
level is what it has to do with our
moral emotional ethical life right and
then there's the allegorical where it's
it's like telling a story about
something else and then there's the
anagogical where it talks about you know
divine things and you know what things
will be in glory so there's all this
stuff going on with the Psalms the
Psalms can be interpreted as being about
Christ
so Thomas in the introduction of the
commentary on the Psalms he says that
the Psalms are in effect a fifth gospel
you know you've got Matthew Mark Luke
and John each of them who's an
evangelist writing a gospel a story
about this this Jesus guy and then
sometimes sometimes people want to say
Paul's letters comprise another gospel
Thomas says the Psalms act as a fifth
gospel so a commentary on the Psalms is
really important so for him to say
halfway through Psalm 54 no I'm not
doing any more that's him that's a big
thing he also doesn't finish his
commentary on Aristotle's politics
either
that's another thing he was working on
and he starts to go to Lyon for a
general council he never makes it there
he hits his head on a tree branch from a
fallen tree and he winds up at the
Cistercian modest
Darien Fossum Nova and there he he dies
and that's that's the end of his bodily
existence but you know if you think
about his works and you see some of the
works in here they comprise a whole
bunch of different things and I didn't
even include all of his works he also
had sermons that he wrote he wrote a lot
of commentaries on Aristotle on boethius
on well on another guy's pseudo Dionysus
he also wrote commentaries on biblical
books he wrote disputed questions and of
course then there's the two sohma's the
Contra Gentiles the smaller one and the
Summa theologia unfinished much larger
one so he was constantly working
constantly writing constantly generating
texts and when he he dies he doesn't
take too long before he's actually
canonized and by 1278 the dominican
general chapter imposes Thomas's
teachings on the order they say that for
Dominicans this is the official
philosopher that you're gonna you're
gonna learn not the only philosopher but
he's gonna be he's gonna be the one for
us Franciscans they've got their own
guys they're not big on Thomas they
never have been but Thomas is gonna go
like in and out of vogue throughout
history so for quite a while like
actually you know shortly after his own
time there's a resurgence of the
Franciscans if you think about who the
really big heavy hitters are Duns Scotus
you know William of Ockham these are
these are other people who are
presenting you know new ways of looking
at things and doing kind of similar work
to what Thomas was doing but starting
with different assumptions and
articulating things in different ways
but the Dominicans you know they
continue on with with Thomas he kind of
goes out of vogue for a while by the
time of the modern era the Jesuits have
arisen and they
kind of you know before the the
Dominicans and the Franciscans they were
like the real go-getters when the
Jesuits show up you know that's where
the sort of center of gravity shifts to
the the Dominicans and Franciscans are
still doing a lot of good work but but
you know the the Jesuits start churning
out thinkers and you know getting
involved in the politics of the time and
when it comes to like Christian
philosophy in the West there's a lot of
within the Catholic tradition after the
you know the Reformation there's a lot
of kind of foundering around like you
know not being sure about exactly who
who should be used as the philosophical
basis should it be st. Thomas should it
be done SCOTUS should be somebody more
contemporary there's all sorts of
attempts to produce new Catholic
philosophies many of which end up
getting condemned you know like good
example Rosa Meany coming up with his on
to law jism the people like de bon all
Dan de Maistre and la Monnaie coming up
with traditionalism after the French
Revolution both of which get condemned
and then something happens that that
radically changes Thomas's stature
something that I think creates a kind of
illusion in the history of ideas for for
many many people in the 20th century
Pope Leo the 13th is known mainly for
two encyclicals one is really important
in terms of social theory it's called
the REA room navara about new you know
new things and it lays out the outline
of a new Catholic social theory that
that informs the social teachings of the
church you know something that would be
able to respond to the new industrial
capital age without going into Marxism
right so it defends private property but
it says private property is not an
absolute right like the the way that
some of these natural right theorists
and capitalists think it is
but it is a right unlike what the
Communists over here are saying right
and so he's steering a path and Catholic
social theory until really the 1950s was
its own very robust tradition kind of
kind of falls out of the framework after
that the other thing that he wrote was
called a tyranny Patras and it's it's
translated as with it like a subtitle on
Christian philosophy and the attorney
Patris suggests returning to Thomas
Aquinas it says that that Thomas it
suggests returning to the Scholastic's
to begin with but says Thomas should be
given like pride of place among all of
them and a lot of people interpreted
that as a call to make Thomas the
official church philosopher and
sometimes the only church philosopher
with you know maybe you'll do a little
bit of Augustine as well and a little
bit of Ansem but for the most part hi
for the most part it'll just be Thomas
Aquinas and it'll be Thomas Aquinas is
Summa often in a very dumbed down
version they would write these manuals
and you know it really got away from the
spirit of Thomas's work which is to you
know like we said before train the the
reader to become you know sort of an
intellectual doer by engaging in this
whole process of sifting through all
this stuff I actually call it a
fundamentalism of the soma it's sort of
like how fundamentalists are with the
Bible where they're like I don't
actually need to interpret this it tells
me exactly what I need to know I just
need to like find the right entry and
the right verse and this will handle
everything that's the way a lot of
old-school Thomas are about Thomas
Aquinas and there are many young young
people today within you know
conservative parts of the church who
have a similar viewpoint on Thomas
they're there again like like
fundamentalists of the soma and it goes
totally against the spirit of Thomas's
thought and works in life but you know
it's understandable
they would they would arrive at that
that view I mentioned that Protestants
have become very interested in Thomas
Aquinas lately which is kind of a weird
thing because you know there's all this
bad blood between Protestants and
Catholics right but more conservative
Protestants have come to see Thomas's
apparatus of thought is incredibly
robust and as not falling into some of
the problems that the you know modern
Protestant philosophy seems to have
fallen into according to them so they
want to return to Thomas and I was very
surprised to find this out
I participated in this dialogue between
Wesleyan and Catholic philosophers I
went to the Wesley and philosophy
Society and they you know it was down in
all of it Nazarene in near Chicago I
don't remember exactly what municipality
which by the way used to be a Catholic
school used to be run by the it used to
be st. Viator's and they you know they
ended up selling it often though
Nazarenes bought it and so they're
having this philosophy conference there
and I was so surprised that so few of
the Catholic philosophers knew anything
about st. Thomas and all of these Wesley
ins they were like bringing him up left
and right I was like what's going on
with this then I started doing a bit
more digging and found that it wasn't
just them it was Presbyterians it was
Methodists it was well Methodists fit
into the Wesleyan thing it was people
from other churches who are reading
Thomas Aquinas as well so he's a hat
sort of a resurgence the other thing
they'll say - about his contemporary
existence is there's a problem of what
Alistair McIntyre is called it in a book
chapter too many tome isms you know you
take Thomas Aquinas and he's written so
much in order to make him work you have
to interpret him and so you have to
decide what's most fundamental in his
work so what what direction do you take
with it and what else do you bring in
from the contemporary world so it's not
as if there is eight home is amout there
there's a plurality of different tome
isms different interpretations of Thomas
and they range from the very
conservative with like retinol Reginald
Gary gula garage all the way over to
some very liberal interpretations and
all sorts of things in between
Alistair McIntyre himself calls himself
a Thomas and I think he has good good
right too because his approach to things
is basically tow mystic as well so
you've you've got this this guy who
winds up being very different in our own
time in the picture that we have of him
is like the authoritative teacher from
what he was in his own time which was a
guy who almost got himself in trouble I
think you know was moving around from
place to place teaching this new radical
Aristotelian philosophy that he's trying
to you know combined with the the other
stuff and not fall into what the really
radical people were doing you know it's
a very different figure this this Thomas
who we know from his own time compared
to the Thomas that many people think
about in the present so that takes us
through through through quite a lot of
stuff yeah do you have any questions or
yeah yeah he reconciled his philosophy
approach Anna's theology approach yeah
in contradiction or does he use the
theology as the basis for the they're
gonna they're in a tension with each
other and and tension can turn into
contradiction right but it can also be
something that that produces you know
sort of a greater dynamism and so Thomas
is lucky in that he's got a long
tradition behind him of great thinkers
who are facing the same sort of problem
how how do you do Christian philosophy
right is it so Krish is it is it
Christian philosophy by just taking a
assumptions doctrinal assumptions from
Christianity and putting them here and
say these are our starting points now
not philosophize that's not the way
Thomas actually works and that's not the
way a lot of the other people like
Augustine or Ansem worked either there
are some things that they they will do
that way but it's pretty rare usually
they're like saying listen scripture
says this but what the hell does that
mean you know on a literal level it
doesn't even seem to make any sense so
let's figure out what it means and let's
use philosophy to make sense of that and
by the way we'll also use some
comparisons with other philosophers who
staked out positions on you know there's
the thing is there's a lot of things
where Christianity or some some you know
interpretation of it some doctrinal
system is going to be talking about the
same phenomena as philosophies like how
do our emotions influence our will write
is that philosophy or is that theology
well it's both because they
interpenetrate each other and oftentimes
what ends up happening is philosophy
goes this far and then theology gives it
a bit more information than philosophy
goes on further that's the way it works
and like you know these classic
philosophers and that's what Thomas is
doing from the perspective of people in
the present it often seems as if Thomas
is just just starting from theological
starting points and that disqualifies
him right from the perspective of people
in his present they're like there's way
too much Aristotle here and so that
could disqualify him as well and he's
he's like walking this tightrope in
between the people who are like no
Aristotle's get that crap out of here
you know and the people who are like
Aristotle is great these religious
people need to shut the hell up he's
walking this this tightrope in between
him trying to say can't we combine this
stuff and you look at the old images of
him there's a lot of iconography of
Thomas who were like one hand he's
holding the church and the other hand
he's holding like a book
or set of books and the idea is he wants
to balance both of them together you
know tough to do you know and it
requires it's not the sort of thing you
could just like decide you're gonna do
as an approach and be like okay now I'll
just jump in and do that I think it's
the sort of thing you have to be
initiated in and so his time under
Albert the Great was probably a very
important formative period for that and
and maybe you know if he'd joined the
Benedictines maybe he wouldn't done that
you know being involved in an order that
was so young and fresh and dynamic and
engaging with new ideas probably played
an important role you know you mean like
within the the institution of the
Dominicans itself not really he was sort
of sort of a workhorse you know he gets
sent out to these different places to
establish schools he must have been a
good administrator you know as well as a
good teacher and he doesn't seem to be
particularly interested in determining
policy or anything like that he is an
intellectual you know he wants to he
wants to write and teach and that sort
of thing and you know do you remember
the Peter Principle
that book from a long time ago in a way
by doing that he probably made himself
happier and kept himself from rising too
you know him who knows maybe he would
have been competent to be the general of
the order or something like that but he
wouldn't gotten much done right he
wanted to get stuff done in terms of
intellectual development and study any
you know contemplation this is the life
he wants to live so by you know by not
being ambitious you know you you would
insure yourself a more manageable
intellectual life because there's lots
of examples of great Christian thinkers
who allowed themselves
to be pulled upward into the hierarchy
and some is a great example he wasn't
happy as a bishop you know he didn't
want to be a bishop he he wasn't even
happy as an abbot he wanted to be just
be a regular monk you know studying
stuff maybe Pryor was fine because then
he teach but he didn't want these
advancements Gregory the first the Pope
who writes the moralia on job where we
get the seven deadly sins from and
writes a number of other important works
including a life of st. Benedict he
didn't want to be Pope he didn't even
want to be like you know he would want
to be a monk and be left the hell alone
so it's tough and unfortunately he he
said yes when it was the sort of thing
where he took on the job because there
wasn't anybody else who could do it he
was he was working at when the Roman
Empire is falling apart right so there's
not a lot of talent Thomas actually has
the luxury of being in an order which
has attracted a lot of really bright
minds so there's there's talent there he
doesn't have to do everything you know
that's the kind of organization you want
to be in yeah do you have any other
questions or glue for now well I don't
have anything else on my end so let's
call it a close and thanks for coming
out and next time is jean-jacques
rousseau
[Music]
you